so today we welcome 2022 happy new year
by the way to all of you at home it's
the biggest party of the year it sure is
the fireworks show is back we're so
excited about that couple hundred
thousand people expected to party you
know give or take
officials though are urging please use
caution pandemic's still not over hector
mejia live at the strat with
preparations that are underway right now
so many hard-working folks hector to
make this go off
without a problem
that's true but first you know we
already have a show right behind us this
is the last sunrise of 2021 or the first
minutes of daylight out here as we all
get ready to welcome in
2022 and off to the right we have the
las vegas strip pretty quiet right now
but this morning crews will start
rolling out around 4 000 crowd control
metal barricades up here at the strat
this is one of the eight launching pads
where right now you're taking a live
look as you can see out here uh some
fireworks already set up here for the
massive show eight minutes long
tradition back here in town finally and
joining us side we have skyler he's here
with the uh strat to talk to us about
celebrations here how are you guys
preparing good morning sir good morning
well here at the strat new year's eve is
a special and unforgettable experience
and we're really focusing on the safety
of our guests and team members for the
firework display and in the casino and
at the parties at the resort as well one
of the things that makes you know the
strat unique is obviously the big o
tower but also you guys are able to have
a watch party while these fireworks are
just popping off oh it's phenomenal
we're going to have a great
dinner planned at the top of the world
prior to that we've got a great party at
the 108 level still tickets available
strat.com there's gonna be a great
viewing experience in there we're really
looking forward to a great party
kicking off 2022. awesome sir thank you
so much for hosting us again this year
we were here last year december 31st of
last year so i want to show you guys one
more thing check out the pyrotechnics
that have been set up here it takes
around 11 000 electrical circuits to
power the fireworks and again this is
one of the eight launching pads across
the las vegas strip and in case you were
wondering once the party is all over
crews will be
removing an estimated 10 to 12 tons of
trash along las vegas boulevard before
they can reopen that to traffic
reporting live hector mejia live local
now happy new year all right hector
happy new year to you you know we know
it's going to be a lot of fun but it is
a lot of work for a lot of people so we
thank them for all that and the cleanup
as well we did get a behind the scenes
tour at planet hollywood's rooftop one
of the sites for america's party
fireworks by grucci once again
coordinating that eight-minute show this
year's theme deuces wild
loading in they're finishing up today
they'll be
completed by tomorrow with all their
testing and all that so
we're excited so we can't wait for
you know midnight tomorrow
it's all choreographed from the mgm
grand aria planet hollywood
caesars ti the venetian and where you
just saw hector at strat resorts world
also added to the lineup this year